il
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat dans 15 minutes les questions
d'actualité les traditionnelles
questions d'actualité nous sommes jeudi
nous allons traiter d'une question
d'actualité avec des invités qui vont
venir nous rejoindre jusqu'à 16h30
mais en attendant ces questions
d'actualité en direct sur notre antenne
une question très importante avec hervé
maurey bonjour vous êtes sénateur
centriste de l'eure vous avez on va dire
jeter un pavé dans la mare ce matin avec
un rapport sur les déserts médicaux
je prends juste cet exemple c'est vous
et par exemple voulait exclure de la
sécurité sociale les praticiens qui
veulent s'installer dans les zones qui
sont déjà sur dotées vous y allez quand
même très fort écoutez c'est un
dispositif qui existe déjà pour
quasiment tous les professionnels de
santé
je vous signale que depuis 2008 c'est ce
qui existe pour les infirmières ça a été
ensuite étendu au kiné puis aux sages
femmes puis aux chirurgiens dentistes et
finalement aujourd'hui il n'y a que les
médecins qui peuvent s'installer
librement où il vole donc nous ce qu'on
propose c'est d'étendre ce dispositif
aux médecins comme ça existe d'ailleurs
en allemagne depuis 25 ans le médecin et
s'installe oui veut il a la liberté de
s'installer mais silva dans une zone
surdotée et bien il ne bénéficie plus du
conventionnement et al'inverse silva
dans une zone sous dotée il bénéficie
des aides à l'installation et je vous
signale que j'évoquais tout à l'heure le
fait que ça existait pour les
infirmières que ça marche puisque en
trois ans le nombre d'infirmières en
zones sous-dotées a augmenté de 30%
excusez-moi hervé maurey mais on peut se
demander pourquoi est-ce que ça n'a pas
été fait jusqu'à présent
j'imagine que d'autres ont eu l'idée
avant vous notamment que les infirmières
si ça fonctionne c'est pourquoi parce
qu'on s'attaque un lobby quand même très
puissant celui les médecins qui peut
très bien descendre dans la rue du jour
au lendemain est ce que vous voulez que
je réponde très franchement s'il vous
plaît je crois que c'est la réalité
nicolas sarkozy avait commencé par dire
qu'il fallait étendre le dispositif qui
existait pour les infirmières aux
médecins et puis après il a dit qu'il
fallait surtout rien touché jean marc
ayrault il y a deux ans il signait une
proposition de loi qui était bien plus
forte que ce que nous proposons
il précisait que pour s'installer en
zone surdotée il fallait une
autorisation donc c'est le régime de
l'autorisation préalable délivrée par l'
agence régionale de santé
mais aujourd'hui les plus du tout sur
cette position
donc on voit bien que nos gouvernants
qu'ils soient de droite ou qu'ils soient
de gauche ils ont peur de déplaire à la
communauté médicale
ce que nous disons parce que c'est le
travail pour hâtif c'est un travail que
qui n'est pas mon travail c'est un
travail qu'il travail d'un groupe
d'étude présidée par le sénateur
socialiste jean luc fichet dans lequel
il y avait des sénateurs de tous les
groupes
nous avons dit à l'unanimité qu'il était
temps d'agir vraiment et qu'il était
temps de prendre des mesures en se
souciant uniquement de l'intérêt général
et pas des intérêts ou des craintes de
tel ou tel
nous accueillons sur ce plateau
également françois patriat sénateur de
côte-d'or c'est un socialiste
merci d'avoir répondu présent à notre
appel quand vous entendez
et que vous voyez le rapport qui a été
validé ce matin cette proposition de loi
de mme moret qu'est ce que vous répondez
notamment sur les déserts médicaux et
cette proposition d'exclure par exemple
de la sécurité sociale ces médecins qui
s'installerait dans ces zones le plus
important to a déjà beaucoup de médecins
les présidents de région sont déjà posé
ce problème depuis déjà plusieurs années
nous avons tenté d'y répondre avec les
moyens qui étaient les nôtres
il ya deux façons de voir les choses
soient la coercition c'est celle que
propose monsieur murray soit la citation
le gouvernement et marisol touraine
aujourd'hui a choisi l'incitation parce
que dans le premier cas on a vu que ça
ne pouvait pas fonctionner aujourd'hui
que ça ne correspond pas je ne
correspond pas à notre société actuelle
alors le choix de l'incitation qui fait
pour les déserts médicaux savait que par
le passé j'ai vu sous le gouvernement
précédent
les régions bien seul pour aller trouver
des médecins étrangers qui veulent
s'installer en territoire rural que nous
avons accompagné pour lesquels nous
avons trouvé des logements des locaux
nous avons construit des maisons
médicales sans l'aide de l'état tout
seul on a réussi comme cela installée de
jeunes médecins
le stage obligatoire en milieu rural la
découverte du territoire rural dans les
déserts médicaux et plus incitatif que
la coercition d'accord si je vous
entends bien ça ne vous plaît pas trop
ce que propose hervé maurey ses lunettes
trop libérale à votre goût c'est ça
c'est non françois patriat dans la
majorité avec erin général vous êtes
tous les deux des élus de terrain donc
vous pouvez aussi vous mettre d'accord
peut-être que si je peux répondre ce que
nous proposons c'est pas la coercition
c'est de la régulation est ce que nous
proposons c'est d'avancer sur deux
jambes la jambe de la régulation et en
même temps la jambe de l'incitation ski
le ski pose problème en france c'est
qu'il n'ya que l'incitation et en
allemagne ils ont fait l'inversé ils ont
mis en place que de la régulation et
maintenant ils complètent par de
l'incitation donc il faut ses deux
jambes
et quand marisol touraine vient nous
dire que ce que nous proposons aux
positions il y ait des armes comme un
seul tour elle vient nous dire que ce
que nous proposons ne serait pas juste
moi je lui réponds est ce que c'est
juste quand sur un territoire vous devez
attendre 18 mois pour avoir un rendez
vous avec un spécialiste alors que sur
d'autres territoires vous avez ce rendez
vous en deux jours
c'est ça l'égalité des citoyens dans la
république sur patriat vous répond c'est
pas le pour ledit spécialiste du tout
aujourd'hui ça n'a rien à voir vous
d'évoquer deux problèmes le problème des
déserts médicaux
c'est du canton de france mais quand
d'habitants où il n'y a plus en région
bourgogne
il y à seize cantons on n'y a plus de
médecin aujourd'hui est ce pas parce que
demain offrit la coercition qu'ils iront
s'installer dans ces territoires là
parce qu'il ya des médecins femmes de
plus en plus nombreux qu'il faut de la
cité par de différentes manières pas
seulement par de l'argent par des
conditions de travail par des
regroupements de médecins par des des
conditions qui leur permettent d'exercer
pleinement leurs activités tout en ayant
une vie de famille c'est cela qu'il faut
aujourd'hui plutôt je crois impulsé que
la coercition qui l amènera une
rébellion de la part du corps médical et
qu'il ne réussira pas c'est d'abord à
françois patriat d'abord apprendre à
passer sur françois patriat simplement
que que ses collègues socialistes qui
ont travaillé avec moi pendant six mois
sur le sujet sont arrivés à des
conclusions totalement inverse puisque
je rappelle que ce rapport n'est pas le
mien c'est celui d'un groupe de travail
qui a approuvé à l'unanimité ces
propositions comme l'a fait ensuite dans
la foulée il ya deux jours la commission
compétente du sénat est ce que vous avez
eu des réponses de marisol touraine et
ce qu'elle vous a entendu est ce que
vous avez discuté avec elle sur cette
proposition pas comme je l'indiquais
elle est venue devant la commission avec
ce propos absolument extraordinaire qui
est de dire ça ne serait pas juste et
c'est là où je réponds est ce que c'est
juste d'attendre des rendez vous chez un
médecin
et si c'est si injuste que cela pourquoi
alors madame touraine ne ne supprime pas
la régulation qui existe déjà pour les
autres professionnels de santé parce que
je rappelle que tous les professionnels
de santé sont régulés en france les
pharmaciens ca date d'il ya soixante ans
on a ajouté en 2008 les infirmières puis
les kinés et puis les sages femmes puis
les chirurgiens dentistes
puis les orthophonistes et ces
professionnels qui sont régulés
interroger les infirmières par exemple
elles sont tout à fait satisfaits du
dispositif et elle ne demande absolument
pas ce qu on revient dessus
en revanche ces professionnels ne
comprennent pas de voir que tous les
professionnels de santé
aujourd'hui aucune installation réguler
sauf les médecins a justement ça va nous
amener sur un dialogue social qui est
très important en ce moment est ce que
vous diriez pas la même que le
ital que la médecine française est en
crise connaissait bien maintenant ce
domaine et après françois patriat vous
répondre sur cette question aujourd'hui
un problème notamment pour avoir des
médecins on revient quand même à ce
problème que ce soit dans les hôpitaux
que ce soit en ville parce que les
déserts médicaux s'est pas seulement
dans les cantons ruraux
c'est aussi dans les banlieues dans les
quartiers et donc il ya effectivement un
problème auquel il faut s'attaquer
donc on est face à une crise françois
patriat notamment sur cette question de
santé qui est très importante pour les
français 74% des français disent que
l'hôpital public aujourd'hui marche bien
au ski déjà quand même un très bon score
reste que plus de 20 % des français
disent le contraire
la santé c'est avec le travail la
deuxième priorité les français c'est
d'abord l'emploi
ensuite la santé ensuite le logement
doit l'être aux priorités
il ya de grandes disparités sur ce
territoire mais ce que je vois dans
votre sondage c'est que les français
font confiance à l'hôpital public
ça prouve que l'hôpital public avec
l'éthique des médecins qui vivent
aujourd'hui de nature accueillir tout le
monde tout le temps pour des conditions
acceptables avec à la fois la rapidité
et l'efficacité qu'on connaît donc
défend le secteur public c'est bien
aujourd'hui reconnaître que les efforts
faits par les ars sur le territoire de
rationalisation contre parfois des élus
qui sont un peu archéo à la matière qui
voudrait garder tous partout on peut pas
avoir des maternités partout malgré le
débat qui a eu récemment bien sûr un
fait divers qui a eu lieu très rares à
avoir des plateaux chirurgicaux partout
quand on connaît la difficulté qu'on a
trouvé des anesthésistes faire un
plateau technique sandales et
aujourd'hui on le fait mettre des irm
sans plateau technique à dos et c'est
difficile aussi
je crois que les choix qui sont faits
sur le territoire l'organisation qui
part souvent des chu donne satisfaction
de mieux satisfaction que par le passé
bien sûr ça c'est la santé ça concerne
tout le monde mes autres sujets qui
concernent aussi la majorité des
français c'est l'emploi la situation
sociale vous diriez aujourd'hui que nous
sommes là aussi face à une flambée
peut-être qu'il va pouvoir qui va
sûrement commencer avec de nombreuses
manifestations l'a vu la semaine
dernière avec les salariés de goodyear
ou d'autres usines
écoutez on voit très clairement que
malgré les
les promesses que l'on a pu entendre la
situation de l'emploi ne s'améliore pas
et je crois que personne ne peut
sérieusement penser que les annonces du
gouvernement selon lesquelles le nombre
de chômeurs diminue très inférieur à la
fin de l'année 2013
personne ne peut penser que ce sera tenu
on voit moi je suis élu d'une région où
il ya petroplus j'ai pas besoin de vous
expliquer toutes les déceptions qui
peuvent être présentes sur le terrain à
la suite de promesses hâtif qui ont été
faites et qui aujourd'hui tombent à
l'eau donc justement si on reste sur le
cas de petroplus juste une petite minute
aujourd'hui petroplus est dans une
situation où c'est l'échec annoncé
arnaud montebourg va répondre à une
question et dans quelques dents quelques
minutes en direct dans l'hémicycle où il
devrait peut-être aussi faire des
annonces sur les repreneurs finalement
n'y aura peut-être pas de repreneur pour
petroplus
écoutez on peut le craindre moi je ne
sais pas comment cette histoire va se
terminer mais ce que je sais c'est que
on a joué avec avec le malheur des gens
on a promis aux gens que si on est élu
et bien il y aurait plus de
licenciements
et puis on est rattrapé par la réalité
et donc forcément il ya de la déception
parfois même de la colère et c'est ça
qu'il est extrêmement dangereux
quand vous faites des promesses que vous
ne tenez pas il ya forcément de la
déception de la colère
merci beaucoup hervé maurey je sais que
vous avez un train donc on va vous
laisser on va vous laisser partir la
cette réponse notamment sur le climat
social
il vous plaît vous ce gouvernement dans
cette action sur le social aujourd'hui
je crois que le gouvernement appuie sur
les deux leviers nécessaires
le premier c'est les mesures économiques
qu'il prend pour tenter de désendetter
la france en tout cas d'arrêter la
spirale infernale de l'endettement
le deuxième quand leur gouvernement
rétablit dialogue social quand le
gouvernement nomme des commissaires sur
le territoire je les vois tous les jours
en région bourgogne fonctionne venir
venir écouter les entreprises trouver
des solutions une solution' pas tout
mais il apporte pour partie des voies
qui permettent à des entreprises soit de
se maintenir
soin de ne pas disparaître soit de
pouvoir recréer alors il s'agit pas de
promesses ou pas de promesses
électorales
il s'agit de créer un contexte
économique et social qui permettent aux
investisseurs d'investir aux entreprises
qui connaît des difficultés actuellement
passagère du fait je pense en
particulier au btp de pouvoir avoir des
investisseurs que sont les collectivités
locales
je ne dis pas que nous avons fait
promener seins du pas du tout le
gouvernement a fait deux anglais a pris
deux engagements
les emplois d'avenir et le contrat de
génération texte maintenant sont votées
sont ressemblés d'avenir par exemple il
n'ya que 4600 emplois d'avenir signé
depuis le 4 février d'un intense cent
mille à la fin de 2013 ça sera très dur
françois patriat non je pense qu'on n'y
arrivera parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de collectivités qui
réfléchissent aujourd'hui la façon de le
faire intelligemment
moi je le fais dans le cadre de la gps
et territoriales aujourd'hui les régions
s'engager département s'engage les
communes s'engagent aussi ses choix sont
elles qui ont signé des contrats
d'avenir nous enseignons sur le terrain
aidés le préfet chaque semaine rencontre
au gouvernement non pas des efforts mais
des travaux qu'il fait pour que nous
puissions arriver
effectivement à les réaliser je crois
que les 2400 emplois d'avenir pour la
bourgogne et bien nous les sinon
françois patriat je voudrais m'adresser
cette fois aux sénateurs et vous faire
écouter un extrait du président du sénat
il était invité ce matin d'une radio rtl
vous allez l'écouter et je voudrais que
vous réagissiez juste après aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans un sénateur mullan
certes mais dans un sénat qui est en
train de montrer une voie différente qui
peut être peut permettre des évolutions
dans les mois à venir quant à ma propre
à ma propre attitude je crois qu'elle
est liée aussi à ce que je suis de fait
je dérange je dérange parce qu'on
voulait ranger pas j'essaie d'y
réfléchir
non parce que je suis pas un homme du
sérail en axant comme le vôtre oui mais
cette fois des tonnes mais vous avez
connu ça et aussi parce que vous savez
sur un certain nombre de sujets qui sont
essentiels dont on va parler par exemple
la limitation du cumul des mandats pour
certains le président du sénat qui
pensent que cet engagement du président
de la république est un engagement qui
va dans le bon sens ben je ne m'inscris
pas fidèlement dans les pas de gaston
monnerville e mail je crois que il y a
des convictions qu'il faut porter
jusqu'au bout alors françois patriat il
déroge qui jean pierre bel en la matière
sur le cumul des mandats je ne sais pas
si c'est quand j'allais goûter il n'y a
pas que le cumul des mandats sur ce
sujet j'ai entendu ce qu'a dit ce matin
claude bartolone près dans l'assemblée
nationale qui dit le cumul des mandats
c'est ce que j'ai dit depuis plusieurs
mois est inéluctable nous y arriverons
la bonne date et 2017 jean pierre belzit
dit qu'il dérange aujourd'hui parce que
dans une situation inédite
premièrement la gauche majoritaire au
sénat
deuxièmement dit une majorité turbulente
moi je regrette mais je veux plus loin
majorité déficient cet objet d'une
majorité déficiente parce que il faut à
tout prix
l'appel à la cohérence après l'appel à
la pédagogie il faut aujourd'hui
retrouvé la voie de l'union et que les
groupes de la majorité composent la
majorité présidentielle aujourd'hui se
retrouvent plus aisément en tout cas
plus nettement sur les textes aussi
symbolique que le budget barça c'est le
rouge le président c'est comme ça c'est
le rôle de tous les rôles c'est le rôle
de président de groupe c'est le rôle
président du sénat c'est le rôle du chef
du gouvernement de faire en sorte je
sais qu'ils le font j'espère qu'ils y
arrivent parce que pour l'instant
l'image du sénat n'est pas celle que je
voudrais voir donc
c'est nanopack turbulent mais déficient
sur wii déficient en la matière si on
retire en tout cas ce mot sur le non
cumul des mandats vous l'avez entendu
également vous signaler les propos de
claude bartolone alors finalement ça ne
sera pas avant la fin de ce quinquennat
c'est une très très bonne nouvelle tient
je n'vous nombre ou en tout cas je dis
pas ça pour moi du tout parce que je
m'appliquerai moi-même non cumul c'est
un problème j'ai toujours dit qu'il
fallait que ces traits cette réforme qui
était une demande militante qui est
devenu demande citoyenne soit réglée
pendant ce mandat comme l'a dit le chef
de l'état
il ya mon avis la date butoir de 80 de
2014 le municipal du nac qui n'est pas
crédible elle n'est pas réalisable et je
ne souhaite pas aujourd'hui que un parti
joue contre ces élus contre un parti
joue contre ces élus à ce moment là il
se met en difficulté lune
alors si on dit applicables à la fin de
ce quinquennat c'est à dire 2017 lui ça
s'appliquera comment s'applique à que
tous les tous les candidats aux
élections qui seront postérieure à la
future élection présidentielle devront
s'engager ou noront ne rompe ne pourront
plus postuler qu'à un mandat unique
d'accord on va parler à présent
peut-être un petit peu au niveau
national et de françois hollande plus
particulièrement on dit visiblement et
sur nos écrans les sondages qui serait
dans une meilleure passe en tout cas que
le mois dernier si pauline que ça vous
satisfait aussi mais comment vous
l'expliquez tout le monde savait les
faits mali selon vous tout le monde
savait que l'année 2012 la fin serait
difficile parce qu'il y avait des plans
retardée parce qu'il y avait une
conjoncture économique avec une
croissance toujours très basses je pense
que c'est la méthode de françois
hollande
une dose de françois hollande c'est une
méthode qui marche après marche de fixer
un cap de fixer des objectifs de trouver
les voies de la négociation de s'imposer
sur les grands domaines
vous savez il ya toujours été
soumis aux doutes de certains et bien
aujourd'hui il je crois que le doute
existe beaucoup moins quand on voit à la
fois le discours qu'il a fait à
tombouctou ville est d'accord pour dire
qu'il ya des faits mali vient du site et
en boucle il ya un effet européens hier
il ya un effet européens n'y a pas eu
qu'un effet mali à plusieurs reprises à
l'extérieur et sur des grands sujets
donc sa sortie windows françois hollande
je crois que c'est le personnage
lui-même qui est à la fois très
déterminé mais aussi parfois tout en
rondeur quand il veut faire avancer les
dossiers
merci beaucoup françois patriat va vous
laisser regagné l'hémicycle vous le
voyez sur ces images le président jean
pierre bel président du sénat dont on
parlait à l'instant avec françois
patriat arrive dans quelques secondes
dans l'hémicycle sur le plateau il va
bien sûr présider cette séance des
questions d'actualité de ce mois de
février on va lui laisser la parole dans
quelques secondes
on va le laisser arriver notamment on va
attendre une des questions est l'une des
réponses aujourd'hui très attendue celle
d'arnaud montebourg le ministre et
vidéos de redressement productif qui va
s'exprimer sur petroplus
on en a parlé avec tout à l'heure hervé
maurey et normalisation c'est là aussi a
tout l'air et messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues l'ordre du jour
appelle les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je rappelle que vous disposez de deux
minutes trente ministres et sénateurs
pour pour la réponse
la parole pour la première question
monsieur alain bertrand pour le groupe
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres à ma question
s'adresse à monsieur guillaume garot
ministre de l'agro alimentaire monsieur
le ministre
aujourd'hui et demain se tient à
bruxelles des négociations décisives sur
le cadre financier pluriannuel pour la
période 2014 2020 et de l'accord qui
sera trouvé je suis sûr de maine départ
aussi la pac
il ya donc une certaine inquiétude les
territoires ruraux
il ya deux jours à strasbourg le
président de la république françois
hollande a confirmé que la politique
agricole commune allait voir ses crédits
diminuer
par rapport aux propositions de la
commission européenne et que cela je
cite engendrera nécessairement des
restructurations difficile dans un
secteur essentiel en territoire alors
monsieur le ministre quelles seront ses
restructurations
la pac doit rester bien sûr une
politique forte et équilibrée
je rappelle que notre agriculture est la
première de l'union européenne et
représente 20 % mais sur de l'espace
agricole européen mais au-delà de ces
chiffres la nouvelle pac devra
privilégier les filières de plus en plus
en difficulté et qui sont celles qui
rendent aussi le plus au service au
territoire en terme d'aménagement du
territoire et de développement durable
et l'élevage devra faire l'objet d'une
attention ciblés tout comme les
territoires de l'hyper ruralité pour
lesquels activités agricoles bien sûr
est une question de survie économique
monsieur le ministre le contribuable
européenne comprendrait pas et ils
auraient raison que l'on est de la même
façon un céréalier qui gagnent en
moyenne plus de son synthé 10000 euros
par âme et un éleveur bovin qui dégage à
peine quinze mille euros de bénéfices en
moyenne par an et comme cours je le
redis davantage à l'aménagement du
territoire et à la biodiversité
je suis très attaché à la biodiversité
quand vous le savez c'est pourquoi
c'est pourquoi la prochaine pac devra
instaurer des soutiens spécifiques
il est indispensable de parvenir un
réquilibrage alors on nous en parle
depuis un moment des aides à l'hectare
entre productions végétales des
productions animales à faveur de ces
dernières il en va ni plus ni moins que
de l'avenir de l'élevage dans notre pays
privilégier le financement vers les 50
premiers hectares
comme vous nous l'avez annoncé monsieur
le ministre est une excellente
initiative
mais il convient là encore de
différencier de favoriser le soutien aux
surfaces fourragères
ça doit aller de pair avec l'obtention
d'une convergence nationale de l'aide de
base un paiement de base distingue
quatre surfaces fourragères et non
fourragères ainsi qu'une forte
augmentation des indemnités
compensatrices l'handicap d'actuels les
fameux 10 sa chaîne qui stagne
maintenant quand même depuis de
nombreuses années alors monsieur le
ministre sur le dossier pac je vais
conclure comme ça
quelles sont les positions de la france
dans les négociations en cours et de
quelles informations disposez-vous
quatre critères qui seront
définitivement retenus pouvez-vous nous
rassurer sur le fait que les éleveurs
seront mieux aider et les céréaliers un
peu moins dans le cadre de la politique
souhaitée par françois hollande
président de la république une pauline
murs et justice la parole est à monsieur
guillaume garot ministre chargé de
l'agroalimentaire monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur c'est en effet au
moment où s'ouvre cette séance des
questions au gouvernement au sénat que
débute également le sommet européen qui
viendra donner espérons le un budget à
l'europe pour pour la période 2014 2020
alors vous m'interrogez sur la politique
agricole commune
nous l'avons dit nous l'avons répété et
le président de la république en tête la
pac ne peut pas ne doit pas être la
variable d'ajustement du budget européen
et lors d'un discours très applaudi
qu'il a prononcée
lundi au parlement européen françois
hollande le président la république a
rappelé son attachement au socle des
politiques européennes que sont à la
fois la politique de cohésion et la
politique agricole commune
alors quels sont les principes que nous
défendons pour cette politique agricole
d'abord vous l'avait dit et c'est
tellement important une pac plus juste
c'est l'idée de pouvoir réorienter les
aides en faveur précisément des régions
d'élevage avec l'idée d'une majoration
pour les 50 premiers hectares donc aux
bénéfices là directement des éleveurs
il ya un deuxième principe qui est tout
aussi important c'est une pac que nous
voulons plus respectueuse de
l'environnement
c'est la question du verdissement et
nous avons énoncé un objectif que ce
verdissement souhaite ambitieux avec un
niveau qui soit équivalent à 30 % du
premier payer là aussi ce serait un
changement extrêmement fort et puis au
delà le temps qu'il faut redire
l'ambition de la france de revenir sur
finalement la logique libérale de la pac
et nous avons montré le chemin et nous
avons posé des actes d'abord avec le
maintien des droits de plantation
rappelez-vous que leur dissolution leur
suppression avait été acceptée par la
précédente majorité et bien nous avons
obtenu mais si nous avons obtenu que le
maintien des droits de plantation soit
reconnu à partir de 2015 cette quelque
chose d'essentiel pour l'ensemble des
viticulteurs de français puis nous
travaillons aussi à une stabilisation du
du marché du lait c'est tout aussi
important si nous voulons rassurer
permettre que nos éleveurs ou
producteurs de lait regarde l'avenir
avec confiance
au delà de l'après quotas c'est à dire
au delà de 2015 alors vous voyez
monsieur le sénateur mesdames messieurs
les sénat
heures nous soutenons une une grande
ambition pour l'europe et une grande
ambition pour la politique agricole
commune et qui doit être légitime
cette pac aux yeux de tous aux yeux de
tous les citoyens comme aux yeux de tous
les agriculteurs
ce qui signifie que nous voulons que
cette pac
selon le ministre la diversité de notre
hacker mais nature et soutiennent le
travail de tous nos agriculteurs je vous
remercie
merci que la parole est à madame natacha
bouchart pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur jérôme
cahuzac ministre du budget monsieur le
ministre
alors que l'année 2013 s'annonce comme
la plus difficile pour me compatriote
confrontées à la crise
l'heure devrait être au rassemblement
pour relever les vrais défis de notre
pays avant tout de nature économique les
réformes sociétales que le gouvernement
met en place
sont-elles la priorité des français qui
souffrent
rien n'est moins sûr parmi les vrais
sujets il y a le financement des
collectivités locales
il semblerait que les dotations versées
par l'état devrait être à nouveau
diminué
la presse s'en est fait l'écho un effort
financier supplémentaire considérable de
1 milliard et demi d'euros d'ici à 2015
serait imposée pour financer une partie
du crédit d'impôt compétitivité soit un
doublement du montant prévu par la loi
de la programmation que nous venons de
voter qui prévoyait 750 millions d'euros
par an en 2014 et 2015
en tout ce seront 10 milliards d'euros
d'économies à trouver d'ici 2015 pour
financer ce crédit d'impôt dispositif
complexe dans l'efficacité est mise en
doute par les patrons des pme
bien sûr les collectivités territoriales
doit participer à l'effort de
redressement des finances publiques mais
dans des justes proportions
mais nous n'en sommes plus là est ce
cela un pacte de confiance et de
solidarité conclu entre l'état et les
collectivités locales
la menace est brandie d'une répercussion
très forte sur le fonctionnement des
collectivités à travers la facture du
changement des rythmes scolaires
notamment et sur les investissements en
particulier pour les communes maire de
calais ville de 75000 habitants qui
luttent face à la crise
je suis inquiète et je me fais le porte
parole de tous ces territoires qui
souffrent mais veulent s'en sortir et
attendent surtout d'être soutenu alors
monsieur le ministre puisque ce mot
confiance et votre argument dans vos
relations avec les collectivités
pouvez vous nous expliquer précisément
quelles sont les véritables intentions
du gouvernement en ce qui concerne la
dgf la dde la dsu et la prime
d'aménagement du territoire
merci monsieur jérôme cahuzac mai
il sera chargé du budget merci monsieur
le président madame la sénatrice je vous
confirme que le gouvernement a deux
priorités dans les politiques publiques
qu'ils mettent en oeuvre
la première c'est le redressement des
comptes publics et la deuxième c'est
bien évidemment restaurer la
compétitivité de nos entreprises dont on
sait qu'elle s'est effondrée ces dix
dernières années je vous rappelle que le
déficit du commerce extérieur en 2011
plus de 70 milliards d'euros et que ce
commerce extérieur était excédentaire
encore en 2001 pour mettre en oeuvre la
première politique de redressement des
finances publiques vous savez l'effort
que l'état consent nous en avons
abondamment discuté dans cet hémicycle
lors de l'examen des lois de finances et
il a semblé légitime au gouvernement
ainsi me semble-t-il cas une très grande
majorité d'élus locaux que les
collectivités locales contribuent à cet
ajustement en proportion naturellement
de leur responsabilité dans cet
endettement
vous le savez l'endettement du pays est
en gros de 1700 milliards d'euros l'état
est responsable pour 80% de cet
endettement les collectivités locales et
la protection sociale de 10 % pour
chacune de ces deux administrations et
donc demander un effort aux
collectivités locales correspondant à
10% de l'effort global paraît juste et
légitime j'en veux pour preuve
d'ailleurs que bien peu d'élus locaux ou
qu'ils siègent sur ses bancs n'est
protester contre ce qui fut annoncée par
mes soins au comité des finances locales
c'est-à-dire un effort de 750 millions
d'euros en 2014 et 750 millions d'euros
supplémentaires en 2015 par rapport à
2013 soit un effort au total et sur
trois ans de 2 milliards 250 millions
d'euros quand le budget des
collectivités locales chaque année
madame la sénatrice vous le savez est de
220 milliards d'euros cet effort est
juste parce qu'il est en proportion de
la responsabilité des collectivités
locales dans l'endettement du pays
et puis la deuxième priorité c'est le
rétablissement de la compétitivité de
nos entreprises le crédit impôt
compétitivité emploi nécessite de
dégager une dizaine de milliards d'euros
d'économies et il est envisagé son
qu'aucune décision ne soit prise pour
l'instant il est envisagé de demander
aux collectivités de participer à cet
effort tant il est vrai que tous les
territoires bénéficieront des progrès de
compétitivité que les entreprises
pourrait réaliser par la richesse créée
par l'emploi créé par l'investissement
créé bref par la vitalité soit confortée
soit rétabli dans chacun des territoires
de notre pays
l'annoncé devrait en être faite le cas
échéant au comité des finances locales
vous savez que ces usages au demeurant
je ne peux vous annoncer quoi que ce
soit aujourd'hui dans la mesure où
aucune décision n'est prise en revanche
je peux vous dire ce que le gouvernement
par ma voix ni par la voix de madame
lebranchu que je salue ni par celles des
années skopje que je salue également
je peux vous dire que lors de ce comité
des finances locales le gouvernement
n'annoncera pas il n'annoncera pas ceux
qui étaient dans le programme de l'ump
des élections législatives c'est à dire
un effort de 10 milliards d'euros
demandés aux collectivités locales
cet effort nous avons toujours considéré
qu'il était tout à fait excessif et
déraisonnable
je vous vois protesté madame la
sénatrice et je le comprends car c'est
probablement la mort dans l'âme si vous
aviez gagné ces élections que vous
auriez accepté les décisions du
gouvernement que vous auriez soutenue de
demander 10 milliards d'euros aux
collectivités locales
un effort tout à fait insupportable que
celle ci n'aurait pu évidemment assumer
sans augmenter les impôts de nos
compatriotes chose à laquelle j'en suis
certain vous seriez refusé voilà donc
madame nationaliste que je voulais vous
apporter comme précision je savais ce
que le gouvernement n'annonce rappaz et
je vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour préciser ce que serait la
part des collectivités locales pour
restaurer la compétitivité des
organistes il fut bien mise à mal par
les politiques publiques menées ces dix
dernières années
merci la parole à monsieur le président
françois zocchetto pour le groupe
l'union des démocrates et indépendants
uc merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre mais je crois que c'est
monsieur monde ce bourg qui va me
répondre
en septembre dernier le président de la
république a déclaré se donner 15 mois
pour inverser la courbe du chômage
six mois plus tard un premier bilan
s'impose
chacun sait que le chômage frappe
désormais toutes les familles en france
plus de 3 millions de personnes sont
frappées par ce par ce drame alors que
fait le gouvernement face à ce drame
les contrats d'avenir soit les contrats
de génération pourquoi pas passe encore
pour les commissaires au redressement
productif mais vous pouvez énumérer
toutes ces mesures vous pouvez annoncer
des chiffres invérifiables
vous ne nous proposerait dans le
meilleur des cas que la perspective
d'une économie administrée à grand
renfort de contrats aidés tout en jetant
sssa probablement le pire tout en jetant
l'opprobre sur les entreprises qui sont
pourtant le seul moteur de la croissance
alors monsieur le ministre nous n'avons
pas les moyens d'une politique des
années 80 chacun sait que les deniers
publics manquent cruellement
c'est à dire avec une grande inquiétude
que nous ouvrons appris que les
collectivités territoriales devront
faire un effort supplémentaire de 5
milliards d'euros
nous n'avons pas non plus le temps de
nous raconter des histoires l'heure
n'est plus à rejeter la faute sur vos
prédécesseurs
l'heure n'est pas non plus à occuper le
parlement avec des sujets qui ne sont
pas la priorité des français mariage
mode de scrutin droit de vote des
étrangers statut du chef de l'état tout
cela permettez moi de vous le dire
appareils comme de plus en plus décalé
quand la colère sociale gronde et vous
le savez bien
on ne termine pas à ses fins de mois
avec des promesses de lendemains qui
chantent
quand on ne sait pas de quoi demain sera
fait
quand on ne sait pas si l'on conservera
son emploi quand on ne sait pas si ses
propres enfants obtiendront un emploi ne
pensez vous pas monsieur le ministre que
l'urgence réside dans le retour des
sujets économiques et sociaux
cette urgence n'est-elle pas dans la
restauration de notre compétitivité et
dans le soutien de notre industrie
plutôt que dans la division des français
sur des sujets sociétaux et puisque vous
voulez parler des sujets sociétaux et
bien ne croyez vous pas que le véritable
sujet de société aujourd'hui c'est la
question du chômage
quand allez-vous faire enfin ce vrai
choc de compétitivité avec la seule
solution réaliste et même s'il existe
des divergences de vues au sein de votre
gouvernement
je vous le demande la baisse directe la
seule solution réaliste c'est bien la
baisse directe des charges des
entreprises compensé par une tva qui
frappe les produits importés
je vous remercie
si la parole que monsieur arnaud
montebourg ministre lui redressement
productif
monsieur le sénateur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs sur le
sénateur le gouvernement considère en
effet comme vous le lui suggérer à juste
titre que le chômage est le principal
problème de notre pays et les risques
économiques qui pèsent sur la france
je voudrais d'ailleurs vous en démontrer
l'importance puisque l'essentiel des
décisions que nous avons prises
nonobstant les cinq mille amendements et
l'agitation parlementaire que vous
plaisez à entretenir sur des questions
qui vous paraissent pourtant mineurs je
voudrais vous dire que nous avons pris
un certain nombre de décisions
importantes
nous avons d'abord stabiliser
l'environnement fiscal des entreprises
c'est l'arbitrage du premier ministre
dans le pacte de compétitivité
cinq mesures fiscales ont été
stabilisées pour cinq ans ça n'a jamais
fait l'objet du moindre engagement
d'aucun de nos prédécesseurs nous avons
faits historiques mis 20 milliards sur
la table des entreprises par un effort
national sans précédent
à tel point d'ailleurs que aujourd'hui
avec oseo
nous rendons praticable et utilisables
ce crédit d'impôt compétitivité qui va
faire beaucoup de bien dans les tpe pme
mêmes grandes entreprises françaises qui
aujourd'hui souffrent en raison de la
réduction de leurs marges
je voudrais également dire que nous
avons fait une mesure d'unité nationale
qui devrait vous réjouir
c'est le crédit impôt recherche inventé
par jean pierre chevènement amplifié par
nicolas sarkozy sanctuarisé par françois
hollande est à la disposition d'ailleurs
des petites et moyennes entreprises
et puisque je ne suis pas à accuser
quiconque de mes prédécesseurs monsieur
le sénateur laissez moi vous dire que un
institut public de recherche vient de
publier les chiffres les trois dernières
années du bilan de la
désindustrialisation notre économie dit
neil 87 usines fermées des centaines de
milliers d'emplois industriels détruits
chacun a sa responsabilité admettons le
mais moi je voudrais vous dire une chose
c'est que maintenant nous devons prendre
le taureau par les cornes
alors oui nous
menon nous menons une politique
d'endiguement sur un grand nombre d
outils industriels de savoir faire
technologique d'entreprises qui risque
de disparaître dans la tornade c'est le
rôle que vous sembliez négligé des
commissaires au redressement productif
je veux le rendre hommage car tous ici
sur ces bancs quel qu'il soit utilisé
commissaire dressement positif lorsqu'il
ya des sinistres dans sa circonscription
où son département
et ils ont raison de le faire je ne peux
que les y encourager en tout cas ce sont
des emplois sauvés je voudrais dire ici
est cité le sénateur arthuis qui je
crois n'est pas très loin de votre
sensibilité
lorsque la château gontier dans la
mayenne nous avons avec le commissaire
redressement productif sauver
l'entreprise
arféo qui est transformé désormais en
scop pour des panneaux de cloisons de
bureau monsieur arthuis déclarait dans
la presse locale
au départ le redressement productif je
pensais que c'était des mots j'étais
dubitatif
aujourd'hui jeudi le redressement
productif ça fonctionne monsieur
zocchetto merci la parole est un
monsieur claude bérit-debat pour le
groupe socialiste et apparentés monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres sharks collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre du
commerce extérieur
madame la ministre les chiffres du
commerce extérieur pour 2012 sont tombés
ce matin
ils montrent que le déficit de notre
balance commerciale a fortement reculé
pour s'établir à 67 milliards contre 74
l'an dernier ces chiffres sont d'autant
plus remarquables qui sont pas tes par
la réduction quasiment de moitié de
notre déficit hors énergie qui passe de
29 à 15 milliards alors que la
croissance européenne reste atone et que
la fracture énergétique s'est alourdi
ces chiffres souligne l'amélioration de
notre compétitivité
en effet nos exportations progresser de
3,2 pour cent et surtout le nombre
d'entreprises françaises qui exportent a
fortement augmenté
et si certains secteurs sont dans une
situation difficile comme l'automobile
beaucoup se sont montrés très
performants
comme l'aéronautique qui a réalisé 20
milliards d'euros d'excédent
cette embellie est donc un signal très
positif pour la france
on le voit le gouvernement agit de
manière cohérente au service de notre
économie
conformément aux engagements du
président de la république vous avez
vous même madame la ministre
inscrire votre action dans une stratégie
de renforcement de notre présence à
l'international
elle repose sur une réforme des
financements à l'export et sur
l'identification des secteurs porteurs
pour nos entreprises
elle s'appuiera sur l'abeille pays et
mobilisera tous les acteurs locaux à
travers la mise en place des plans
régionaux d'internationalisation des
entreprises nos entreprises savent eux
dont maintenant qu'elles peuvent enfin
compter sur un gouvernement qui agit de
manière claire et efficace pour
renforcer leur compétitivité
dans ces conditions madame la ministre
ma question est simple les chiffres du
commerce extérieur de 2012 montre que
nous sommes sur la bonne voie
quelles actions le gouvernement entend
t-il alors menées pour renforcer cette
tendance positive alors que 2013
s'annonce comme une année difficile je
vous remercie
merci madame nicole bricq ministre du
commerce extérieur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bérit-debat vous
avez rappelé que le déficit du commerce
extérieur de la france se réduit mais il
en reste quand même pour 67 milliards
donc ça prouve que effectivement c'est
plutôt un bon signal mais qu'il reste
beaucoup à faire et que l'objectif que
m'a fixé le premier ministre est
d'arriver à un équilibre de la balance
commerciale hors énergie d'ici la fin du
quinquennat
ça veut dire qu'il faut gagner à peu
près 26 milliards d'euros
donc il ne faut pas s'arrêter en chemin
j'y vois un bon signe dans la mesure où
vous l'avez rappelé nous avons eu des
résultats très performant dans ce qu'on
appelle les grands contrats
l'aéronautique
nous avons livré 12 cents aéronefs ce
qui est je crois pour l'aéronautique
française un record historique
nous n'aurons pas tous les ans le même
résultat il faut le souhaiter bien sûr
parce que ça permet quand même je le dis
au passage de créer dix mille emplois
dans la filière aéronautique
donc c'est quand même très important
mais il faut travailler pour que le
commerce courant lui aussi se
développent et le commerce courant c'est
le gros la balance commerciale et ce
sont les pme les pmi et les entreprises
intermédiaires
c'est pour ça qu'ils hier au salon des
entrepreneurs j'ai annoncé que nous
mettions à disposition des entreprises
qui exportent et qui doivent le faire
durablement 150 millions qui sont pris
sur le programme fsi investissement est
mis à la disposition de cdc entreprises
je crois que il faut aussi qu'on ait des
financements compétitifs
on a commencé le faire l'année dernière
il faut continuer et des fonds propres
ça veut dire qu'on a des capacités
d'investir et des capacité d'innover et
quand on innove on exporte et puis
surtout ce qui est intéressant c'est que
dans une europe en difficulté le
commerce s'oriente vers les pays qui
sont des relais de croissance
et ça c'est une nouveauté nous avons
constaté que l'asie était en prod est en
progression de 13% et c'est pour ça que
nous nous occupons beaucoup de ces
terres qui sont plus lointaines plus
loin de nos références traditionnelles
mais où les entreprises françaises sont
présentes elles réussissent et elles
veulent réussir ça veut dire que le
premier ministre et moi-même nous nous
déplaçons beaucoup dans ces pays qui ne
sont pas notre jardin naturel
j'étais en chine il ya quinze jours le
président il sera au mois de d'avril
mais le premier ministre est venu à
singapour aux philippines j'étais avec
lui cette semaine ou en thaïlande
je serai
prochainement en indonésie au vietnam
ce sont des terres de conquête pour nous
mais nos entreprises sont très présentes
est ce que je retiens comme leçon c'est
que le déficit ce n'est pas une fatalité
alors il faut remonter nos manches
il faut poursuivre mais ce que je vois
partout y compris en région j'étais à
marseille dans les bouches du rhône il
ya très peu de temps la semaine dernière
j'ai fait 11 régions et je vois des
entreprises mobilisées des entrepreneurs
entreprenants et qui partent à la
conquête
maintenant il faut les aider du mieux
possible c'est le rôle de l'état un cap
une stratégie des priorités d'action est
ce que j'observe aussi de très positif
c'est que dans certains pays en
croissance
nous avons une offre commerciale qui est
parfaitement en phase avec les besoins
du pays
allons-y et allons-y tous ensemble merci
la peur aux locaux madame kalliopi ango
ela pour le groupe écologiste
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame vallaud-belkacem
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues hier 6 février était
consacrée à la journée internationale
contre les mutilations génitales
féminines
la lutte contre ces crimes que constitue
l'excision la fabulation ou toutes
autres mutilations génitales dont sont
victimes les femmes jeune fille et
petite-fille nous concerne toutes et
tous pour mener efficacement ce combat
il est avant tout nécessaire qu'il soit
visible et notamment dans cet hémicycle
ces pratiques inacceptables concerne
plus de 135 millions de femmes dans le
monde
cette situation dramatique vise
directement la france où le nombre de
femmes excisées estimé à 50 milles il me
semble indispensable de rappeler que ces
combats semaine depuis des années dans
plusieurs pays en afrique en indonésie
et ailleurs grâce au courage de femme
exceptionnelle qui se mobilisent en vue
de l'éducation des filles et qui lutte
aussi contre l'économie de l'excision
nous devons comprendre que les
ressortissants des états concernés sont
plus que jamais mobilisés contre ces
tortures les discours de thomas sankara
contre l'excision sont bien connus plus
récemment le musicien et interprète
ivoirien tiken jah fakoly chantait non
l'excision ne les touchait plus elles
ont assez souffert femmes hommes chefs
d'état tous impliquent donc dans cette
nécessaire lutte
je citerai par exemple le protocole de
maputo signés le 11 juillet 2003 par 53
chefs d'état de l'union africaine et
dont l'article 3 dispose que les
mutilations génitales féminines doivent
être interdite et sanctionnée
concernant la france je tiens ici à
saluer l'immense travail que mène depuis
trois décennies le gams groupe pour
l'abolition des mutilations sexuelles
des mariages forcés prévention
information mais aussi et surtout un
combat judiciaire ayant permis de faire
progresser à la fois les esprits et
notre droit au niveau international
diverses résolutions de l'onu ont été
pris sur ce problème de santé publique
prioritaire
tout comme au niveau communautaire par
le parlement européen
enfin le conseil de l'europe requiert
une attention particulière sur les
demandes d'asile liées au genre sa
convention dite d'istanbul en date du 5
mai 2011 consacre son article 38 à la
lutte contre les mutilations génitales
féminines
madame la ministre j'apprécie et
j'encourage évidemment votre engagement
dans la lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes
mais plus particulièrement sur ces
questions quelle nouvelle initiative le
gouvernement envisage-t-il de prendre
pour accompagner ce mouvement en faveur
de la lutte contre les mutilations
génitales féminines
quand la france va-t-elle ratifié la
convention d'istanbul précités et donc
procéder aux adaptations préalable
nécessaire en droit pénal français
je vous remercie merci madame najat
vallaud-belkacem le ministre les droits
des femmes merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice ango ela
vous avez raison de le souligner plus de
100 millions de femmes à travers le
monde qui sont victimes de cette
pratique barbare intolérable violente
dangereuse et à laquelle aucune
justification ni culturelle ni
religieuse ne peut être trouvée nous
devons d'abord nous réjouir du fait que
le 20 décembre dernier l'assemblée
générale
des nations unies a adopté une
résolution pour en finir une fois pour
toutes avec cette pratique pour s'en
donner enfin les moyens sachez que la
france ça a compté pour beaucoup dans ce
combat qui est mené depuis des années
maintenant et qui a trouvé ce destin le
20 décembre dernier
nous restons mobilisés aux côtés
notamment du secrétaire général des
nations unies sur ce sujet mais surtout
regardons ce qui se passe sur notre sol
la france est l'un des premiers pays à
avoir pris à bras le corps ce sujet et
dès 1983 notamment grâce à l'action du
gams que vous avez eu raison de citer et
auquel il faut rendre hommage à voir
juger et condamner les familles
responsables de ces mutilations
sexuelles féminines
l'excision dans notre code pénal est un
crime qu'elle ait été commise en france
ou à l'étranger il faut leur préciser et
donc c'est un crime qui est jugé en
cours d'assises
nous allons renforcer encore la sanction
à l'égard de ces faits nous allons vous
présenter très prochainement un texte
donc je peux vous informer qu'il a été
adressée au conseil d'état très
récemment
notre projet de loi visant à adapter
notre droit pénal aux dispositions de la
convention d'istanbul
ce projet de loi sera présenté en
conseil des ministres d'ici la fin de ce
mois et il sera aussitôt déposé sur le
bureau de votre assemblée
on vous y proposera en particulier de
faire de l'incitation à subir une
mutilation sexuelle féminine une
infraction en tant que tel ce sera
encore une fois un progrès de plus au
delà du droit ou delà de la vertu
dissuasive des grands procès vous le
savez madame angot et là c'est la
qualité de la prévention qui fera
reculer ces pratiques et c'est pourquoi
nous devons toujours plus informer les
populations les plus exposées en
particulier lorsque elle s'apprête à se
rendre à l'étranger
sachez que nous y travaillons c'est
pourquoi aussi il faut veiller à ce que
ces cas d'excision soit détecter le plus
précocement possible et que nous
puissions intervenir à temps notamment
pour protéger les filles qui sont dans
l'entourage des victimes signalées
le parlement a déjà amélioré la loi il
faut le souligner pour que le secret
médical ne s'oppose plus à ce que les
médecins signal c'est
ces types d'infractions les
professionnels de la pmi joue un rôle
absolument majeur qui est regardé de
très près par les pays étrangers qui
nous envient ce rôle et cette
participation évidemment doit se
poursuivre il faut veiller en
particulier à ce que dans le cadre de la
formation qui sera conduite par
l'observatoire national des violences
faites aux femmes qui vient d'être mise
en place
la question de l'excision et des
mutilations sexuelles féminines soit
considérée comme une violence à part
entière ce sera le cas enfin un dernier
mot pour vous dire que ce qui importe
c'est aussi là prêt et nous avons la
chance d'avoir des professionnels en
france comme pierre foldès qui ont
beaucoup travaillé sur la réparation car
cela aussi ça permet de dire aux
victimes que leur souffrance n'est pas
définitive
pour conclure madame la sénatrice
parlons-en parlons-en c'est le meilleur
service à rendre aux victimes faisant
les parler elle aussi et soutenons donc
comme nous nous apprêtons nous le
gouvernement à le faire cette initiative
des associations qui s'appelle excision
parlons-en et qui verra le jour pendant
l'année 2013 merci merci la parole à
madame la présidente annie davy pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
marisol touraine ministre des affaires
sociales et de la santé
respect des tarifs opposables
non-discrimination soins qualité des
personnels médicaux et paramédicaux nos
hôpitaux sont les fleurons de notre
système de santé pourtant mis à mal par
la loi hôpital patients santé
territoires la loi hpst imposée par
nicolas sarkozy et que nous avions
combattu ensemble
fragilisé par la convergence tarifaire
est victime d'un mode de financement
similaire à celui pratiqué dans les
cliniques commerciales nos hôpitaux
subissent aujourd'hui une situation
économique et financière insupportable
l'insuffisance de l'évolution de leur
crédit et la baisse des tarifs prévue
cette année leur imposera une contrainte
financière telle que selon la fédération
hospitalière de france
cela aboutira à la suppression de 35
mille emplois des femmes et des hommes
pourtant indispensable pour accueillir
pour orienter soigner les patients ou
pour leur apporter toute la sécurité
dont ils ont besoin ce seront également
autant de
fermetures d'établissements d'hôpitaux
de maternités de proximité tels que
marie galante ouvir accroissant de fait
les inégalités territoriales en santé
madame la ministre à l'occasion de
l'examen du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale nous vous avions
fait part de nos craintes
considérant que les moyens mobilisés
pour les hôpitaux publics était
insuffisant aujourd'hui les élus locaux
qui en nombre rejette les schémas
régionaux d'organisation des soins ou
émettent pour le moins d'importantes
réserves vous le savez bien madame la
ministre mais aussi des personnels des
représentants des hôpitaux publics et
les collectifs qui défendent les
hôpitaux de proximité partagent notre
analyse dans l'intérêt du service public
de santé et de nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens il est temps de rompre avec
les logiques libérales imposées par le
précédent gouvernement
pourquoi ne pas instaurer par exemple un
moratoire sur la fermeture des hôpitaux
et cliniques de proximité et sur les
restructurations qui découle de la loi
hpst
pourquoi ne pas stopper la tarification
à l'activité madame la ministre vous
nous avez annoncé un pacte de confiance
pour l'hôpital maintenant les actrices
et les acteurs de ce secteur attendent
des actes quelles mesures urgentes et
pérenne
entendez vous prendre pour assurer un
financement de l'hôpital public à la
hauteur de ses besoins
je vous remercie merci la parole est pas
madame marisol touraine ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales je voudrais
commencer par dire que la france peut
être fière de ses hôpitaux publics et
que les français doivent être fier à la
fois de l'engagement du travail de
celles et ceux qui au quotidien se
dévouent pour permettre à la santé dans
notre pays d'atteindre un très haut
niveau de qualité qui nous est enviée
par nos pays voisins
d'ailleurs les français ne s'y trompent
pas puisque une étude récente montre
qu'ils sont plus de 75% à accorder leur
confiance à l'hôpital public pour les
accueillir pour les soigner pour les
soutenir
et de ce point de vue là il est
absolument nécessaire de rompre
avec la logique qui a prévalu au cours
des années passées qui a voulu que
l'hôpital public soit assimilé dans son
fonctionnement dans ses modes de
construction dans son mode de
financement aux établissements privés et
nous n'avons pas attendu
madame la sénatrice puisque à l'occasion
de la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale des mesures importantes ont été
prises
d'ores et déjà il a été réaffirmé
l'importance du service public
hospitalier
il a été mis fin à la convergence
tarifaire entre le service public et les
établissements privés
nous avons pris des engagements voter
parce qu'ils ont apporté leur suffrage à
la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour que 1 milliard 600 millions
d'euros supplémentaire soit accordé en
2013 à l'hôpital public et c'est un
effort important dans un contexte de
restriction et de nécessaire
responsabilité pour les finances
publiques
mais vous avez raison nous devons aller
au-delà et gelé annoncé un pacte de
confiance doit pouvoir rendre à
l'hôpital public à la fois de l'élan du
dynamisme mais aussi des perspectives
d'avenir de ce point de vue là j'ai
d'ores et déjà installé un comité de
financement qui a pour mission de revoir
les règles de financement et les règles
d'adaptation de la tarification à
l'activité qui ne peut plus continuer à
s'appliquer de manière homogène à
l'ensemble des services hospitaliers de
la même façon nous avons la volonté de
répondre sur tous les territoires
surtout dans tous les bassins de vie aux
besoins de santé de nos concitoyens avec
une exigence madame la sénatrice une
exigence de sécurité et c'est à l'aune
de la sécurité que nous devons examiner
la possibilité de maintenir des
coopérations de renforcer les
coopérations entre les établissements
afin que nos concitoyens puissent
compter sur un service public
hospitalier de qualité vous le voyez
madame la sénatrice le gouvernement a la
volonté de renforcer le rôle de
l'hôpital public de le conforter dans
ses missions
le service public hospitalier est une
des fiertés de la france et nous devons
collectivement faire en sorte qu'il est
un grand avenir
merci la parole à monsieur hugues
portelli pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président madame
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
transports les usagers du transilien ile
de france ont pris malheureusement
l'habitude depuis des années de subir
les dysfonctionnements dans le transport
or depuis le mois de janvier
et bien ce dysfonctionnement a pris une
ampleur nouvelle notamment sur la
principale ligne de transport de toute
la france le rer a
tous les jours des trains sont supprimés
tous les jours des rames arrive en
retard
une autre ligne la ligne j la ligne j
bien voit elle aussi d'être a
régulièrement supprimer des trains
régulièrement arrivé en retard sur la
ligne h où pourtant on a changé les
trains récemment où le transilien est
installé est bien là encore et pas plus
tard qu'hier
tous les jours il y à des suppressions
de trains sur la ligne b sur la ligne c
régulièrement il ya des
dysfonctionnements régulièrement dans
tous ses trains le nettoyage n'est pas
assurée correctement
alors monsieur le ministre je voudrais
vous poser simplement quelques questions
premièrement quand supprimera t-on enfin
l'interconnexion sncf ratp sur les
lignes à b et d
deuxièmement caen introduira t-on enfin
des rames à deux étages sur la ligne à
troisièmement quand la sncf
gagnera-t-elle répondre aux questions
des usagers
quand il lui demande pourquoi les trains
sont supprimés ou arrivent en retard
quatrièmement comment expliquez vous que
les usagers de ces lignes
lorsqu'ils se présentent un entretien
d'embauché se voit poser pour première
question
comment pour comptez-vous venir à votre
travail
quelle ligne transport utiliserez-vous
et lorsqu'ils répondent qu'ils utilisent
les lignes que je viens de vous citer et
bien la plupart du temps leur
candidature est écarté alors monsieur le
ministre nous sommes nous sommes
attachés au service public
nous sommes attachés au service public
des transports nous vous demandons de le
faire respecter
et notamment par la sncf merci
l'appareil est un monsieur frédéric
cuvillier ministre chargé des transports
de la mer et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur et bien nous
apprenons des choses dans cette enceinte
d'abord que depuis le 6 mai la
dégradation des services est à ce point
que vous en fait porter la
responsabilité sur ce gouvernement que
jusqu'à l'odeur dans les rer et autres
transports en commun est remise en cause
la propreté et que nous avons parlé
transports en commun une nouvelle
explication cher arnaud montebourg du
niveau de chômage puisque c'est une des
conditions qui amène à ce que les gens
ne soient plus en situation de poireaux
au delà de la caricature à laquelle vous
vous livrez monsieur le sénateur car
votre intervention
votre intervention qui est une
intervention qui souligne des
difficultés du quotidien elles sont pas
nouvelles elles sont au même récurrentes
et qui est une situation à laquelle nous
nous attaquons depuis dès le premier
jour de la nomination d'abord je vous
ferai remarquer que
permettez moi de vous indiquer un
certain nombre d'informations au delà
au delà des cris qui ne se justifie pas
particulièrement dans cette enceinte
j'ai la conviction et les certainement
partagée que c'est en faisant en sorte
que les opérateurs que le style que la
région que l'état travaille ensemble que
nous pourrons nous pourrons gommer les
dysfonctionnements qui sont trop
récurrent sur l'ensemble du réseau
parisien tout d'abord dans les
prochaines semaines suite au travail qui
a été piloté par cécile duflot le
premier ministre va annoncer les
décisions du calendrier de la
réalisation du plan de financement du
grand paris express
ce grand pas ce plan qui sera annoncée
sera accompagnée également des mesures
d'amélioration du transport du quotidien
et je vous remercie de souligner que
l'un des enjeux qui a été souligné par
le président de la république et qui est
mise en oeuvre par le gouvernement c'est
à dire le transport du quotidien est un
enjeu quotidien précisément est un enjeu
majeur pour ce gouvernement nous faisons
en sorte que par la concrétisation des
engagements qui sont anciens
ces projets ne soient plus du domaine de
la fable mais de la réalité et par
ailleurs nous souhaitons également avec
la région ile de france avec l'état
accélérée des opérations qui visent à
moderniser le réseau existant
modernisation des schémas directeurs du
rer par exemple travail pour faire
aboutir de nouveaux projets
indispensables la désaturation du réseau
je pense ici au projet eole qui est
indispensable les opérateurs l'état la
ratp la sncf sont également aux côtés du
stif pour mener à bien des grands
projets de modernisation du matériel
roulant qui est indispensable à la
régularité et à la qualité a offertes
aux usagers à plomb soit dit en passant
quand même que le style depuis la
décentralisation a lancé un vaste projet
de vaste projet le francilien des rames
à deux niveaux le héros à la rénovation
de matériel roulant sur les rer b c et d
nous avons d'ores et déjà également
demandé l'amélioration de l'exploitation
notamment du centre de commandement
unique de la ligne b qui sera mise en
oeuvre dès 2013 est par ailleurs j'ai
souhaité que cette réflexion soit mise
en oeuvre
sur la ligne à d'autre part le président
de la sncf et de rff d'ores et déjà
anticipé ce qui sera la kz2 la réforme
ferroviaire
c'est à dire de pouvoir coordonner
améliorer l'opel le pilot de ses
ministres il faut finir les travaux
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
monsieur ronan kerdraon
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
michèle delaunay ministre déléguée aux
personnes âgées et l'autonomie et va
louer évalué en 2000 à 800000 les
personnes âgées dépendantes serait
920000 en 2025 1,8 million d'ici 2040
selon l'insee le nombre de personnes
âgées dépendantes explose la raison est
simple la population française vieillit
en 2011 l'espérance de vie était de 84 8
ans pour les femmes et de 78 2 ans pour
les hommes c'est le papy boom
ou plus exactement le mammy blue la
proportion de personnes âgées dont la
population va croître les 60 ans et plus
représentent 15 millions aujourd'hui
ils seront 20 millions en 2030 et 24
millions en 2060 11% auront 80 ans et
plus entre 2010 et 2040 le nombre de
plus de 85 ans évoluerez de plus de 300%
cette évolution représente à la fois un
progrès et une chance mais elle
constitue également un enjeu majeur
il est en effet nécessaire d'adapter la
société française à cette révolution de
l'âge elle explique également pourquoi
la perte d'autonomie est l'une des
premières préoccupations des français
dans cette perspective il devient urgent
d'adopter une grande réforme sur la
perte d'autonomie
une réforme permettant une adaptation de
l'offre de soins tout en intégrant les
besoins sociaux et psychologiques des
patients et leur entourage
promise par nicolas sarkozy en 2007
cette réforme a été repoussée
tout au long du dernier quinquennat
avant d'être abandonné en septembre 2011
et pourtant quatre groupes de travail
avaient été chargés d'établir un état
des lieux et de formuler des
propositions des débats interrégionaux
interdépartementaux ont été organisées à
travers la france qui ont suscité une
véritable attente des professionnels
de toutes les familles concernées et en
particulier des aidants consciente de
cette attente madame la ministre vous
avez demandé à notre collègue députée
martine pinville au docteur jean-pierre
à kino-a luc broussy de réfléchir sur
les mesures d'anticipation de prévention
et d'adaptation de la société face au
vieillissement de la population ces
missions dont les rapports doivent être
rendues dans les prochaines semaines
constitue le prélude à une réforme plus
globale dans cette perspective l'annoncé
faite par le président de la république
au congrès de l'uniopss d'une réforme de
la dépendance avant la fin de cette
année 2013 est une excellente nouvelle
cette réforme de la dépendance viendra
parfaitement compléter la loi sur la
paille mise en place en 2001 par
paulette guinchard chrysler secrétaire
d'état aux personnes âgées dans le
gouvernement de lionel jospin aussi
madame la ministre pourriez vous nous
préciser quelles seront les priorités et
les objectifs de cette loi d'adaptation
de la société au vieillissement pour
gérer avec sérénité solidarité une des
plus formidables progrès des 20e et 21e
siècle celui de l'allongement continu de
la durée de la vie je vous remercie
madame michèle delaunay ministre chargée
des personnes âgées et de l'autonomie
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur cartes card draw vous l'avez
dit le président de la république a
donné le 25 janvier à lille le top
départ de la réforme de la dépendance
elle devra être prête avant la fin de
l'année 2013 et je le souligne ce n'est
ceux ne saura que 18 mois après
l'installation de notre gouvernement
il s'agit d'une réforme ambitieuse qui
couvrira tout le champ de l'avancé en
hqe aucun gouvernement
dans aucun pays n'a fait elle dessine en
particulier le parcours résidentiel des
personnes âgées avec une priorité donnée
à ceux qui est le voeu de 87% des
français rester le plus longtemps
possible à leur domicile
cela passe par l'adaptation de 80 mille
logements et leur aménagement
mais le domicile c'est aussi vous le
savez ces logements intermédiaires ou
launay
parfaitement autonome chez soi mais en
prise directe avec les services et avec
la vie sociale
ce sera aussi et c'est une de nos
priorités
la prévention est l'anticipation qui
constituera un volet majeur de ce projet
de loi
mais le président de la république nous
a également confié la mission de rendre
accessible aux classes moyennes aux
familles des classes moyennes de loi les
plus nombreuses
les maisons de retraite sur le plan
financier
ils font il s'agit de réduire le fossé
devenu totalement inacceptables
inacceptables entre le montant moyen des
retraites 1100 euros pour une femme
les plus nombreuses en établissement et
le montant - le coût moyen pour les
familles des maisons de retraite 1600
euros dans le public
2400 dans le privé commercial
pour cela nous avons mission d'étudier
toutes les pistes
la réduction des coûts le la régulation
des tarifs mais aussi bien sur
l'amélioration des z public
c'est un engagement considérable et nous
le devons
comme nous l'a rappelé le président de
la république un aux familles françaises
aujourd'hui si souvent en difficulté
cent pour cent des familles sont
concernées par la cause de lâches et
nous démontrons d'ores et déjà que cela
constitue une des priorités de notre
gouvernement
merci la parole est à monsieur rené
moment pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
mon propos est ma question s'adresse
bien sûr comme vous le savez déjà à
monsieur le ministre du redressement
productif geminis je vous parlais de
culture ce soir vous parlez d'une guerre
des anciens et des modernes qui a été
réinventée c'est vrai en l'occurrence
et/ou en quelque sorte vous allez le
voir et vous le savez déjà ce mail le
bien bien sûr mais aussi le mal amazon
le distributeur américain haut 50
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
annuel
l'expression même de la mule modernité
numérique du commerce des dvd
dématérialisée arrive chez vous monsieur
le ministre
chez-nous devrais je dire d'ailleurs
1,12 million d' aides publiques 1,12
million d' aide publique pour la
création de 250 emplois sur un millier
annoncé à terme on n'a pas précisé les
termes dans un nouvel entrepôt en
saône-et-loire à ce vrai alors c'est
vrai que dans le contexte économique
ultra déprimé actuel où les
licenciements succès du licenciement
dans tous les secteurs est partout en
france quel que soit la taille des
entreprises le plus souvent d'ailleurs
celle-ci mettant la clé sous la porte
sans crier gare une telle implantation
peut apparaître comme une bonne nouvelle
mais que vous le savez aussi plus rien
n'est simple dans notre monde compliqué
la médaille a un revers et la mariée
n'est pas aussi belle dans le même temps
en effet les 26 magasins de virgin un
grand de la distribution de produits
culturels dans notre pays ont été
placées en redressement judiciaire pour
une période de quatre mois le temps de
trouver éventuellement une solution pour
le millier de salariés encore en poste
chez virgin prompte arrêt à réagir
votre collègue ministre de la culture
madame aurélie filippetti a fait un
parallèle entre cette soluce cette
situation et la nouvelle implantation du
mastodonte américain le rendant en
partie responsables des difficultés des
vases in store mais elle n'est pas la
seule à souligner que cette société
était à l'origine de la cour d'une
concurrence déloyale car elle n'est pas
soumise aux mêmes contraintes sociales
et surtout fiscales que les autres un
véritable front anti amazon des
distributeurs se développent depuis la
fnac aux anciennes aux en scène aux
enseignes pardon de toute la grande
distribution qui dénonce que cette
société paye peu ou pas du tout d'impôts
en france
acteurs eux-mêmes du commerce
électronique en effet sion sion daleux
de donner ses subventions à une
entreprise qui ne méritent pas ou peu
ses recettes
alors monsieur le ministre quelle
incohérence gouvernementale que ce
gaspillage de plus d'un milliard de plus
d'un milliard qu'envisagez-vous pour
éviter ces coûteuses bavure merci la
parole est à monsieur arnaud montebourg
ministre du roi sont improductifs
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur rené beaumont il est vrai que
amazon montre est une façon éclatante
les contradictions de la société
actuelle c'est à la fois un changement
sociétal où de plus en plus de nos
concitoyens font leurs courses à
domicile sans se déplacer et attendre un
service très rapide de livraison à
domicile et il est vrai que le commerce
classique petit moyen ou grand car on
pensait que cela ferait nuisances
d'abord au petit commerce de détail en
vérité y compris à la grande
distribution de détail qui celle-ci
n'échappe pas à cette mutation
généralisée et mondial nous avons deux
solutions la nier ou l'accompagner nous
avons fait le choix de ne pas la nier et
de l'accompagner tout en contestant ces
excès alors je vais vous expliquer et je
me fais le porte parole temps
horaires et amicale d'aurélie filippetti
la ministre de la culture pour vous
répondre
fallait-il ne pas accueillir sur les
territoires où le demandent et amazon il
y en a trois en france
montélimar saran saran dans le loiret
montélimar dans la drôme
sevré en saône-et-loire et amazon a fait
connaître son désir de s'implanter sur
un quatrième site à douai dans le nord
nous parlons donc d'un total de
créations d'emplois d'ici 2015 d'environ
2500 nous avons deux solutions soit dire
nous ne voulons pas de vous quitter la
france ce n'est pas la stratégie que le
ministère du redressement productif a
choisi puisque c'est le ministère de
l'hospitalité économique industriel est
ce que les collectivités locales peuvent
résister à la tentation justifié
humaines et naturelles de dire nous
n'allons pas vous accueillir nous allons
vous rejetez la réponse est non ce ne
serait pas sérieux et vous seriez-vous
ancien président d'un département que je
connais bien le premier à attaquer un
comportement de cette nature donc nous
avons appliqué partout nous l'observons
des règlements qui sont applicables dans
toutes les collectivités locales pour la
totalité des emplois quel qu'il soit et
qui viennent s'implanter sur les
territoires néanmoins monsieur le
sénateur le gouvernement a entrepris des
mesures visant à soumettre les géants de
l'internet à une fiscalité
concurrentielle en tout cas de même
niveau de même nature que les
concurrents c'est bien le minimum nous
ne souhaitons pas que l'union européenne
se transforme en immense paradis fiscal
pour les géants de l'internet et c'est
la raison pour laquelle la france a pris
l'initiative dans une négociation
motrices monsieur le président de faire
évoluer le taux d'imposition en liaison
avec les partenaires européens cette
négociation nous l'espérons devrait
aboutir dès 2015 ne pas rejeter ce qui
est utile et éliminer ce qui est mauvais
je crois que nous pourrons est tous
d'accord en l'état monsieur jean luc
fichet
pour le groupe socialiste apparentés
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre délégué auprès du
ministre agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt chargé
de l'agroalimentaire monsieur le
ministre
aujourd'hui dans notre pays la filière
avicole connaît une crise majeure
or au moment où enfin elle se met en
ordre de marche pour se restructurer
reconquérir le marché intérieur et
extérieur et aborder l'avenir plus
sereinement
la commission européenne a décidé de
manière brutale de réduire de moitié des
aides financières consacrées aux
exportations de viande de volaille
nous savions tous et des entreprises
concernées en premier lieu que les
subventions européennes à l'export ne
durerait pas indéfiniment
vous travaillez monsieur le ministre à
moderniser et à orienter cette filière à
travers un véritable plan stratégique
c'est ce que vous avez annoncé en
déplacement dans mon département le
finistère en décembre dernier comme vous
le rappeliez alors l'agroalimentaire est
une force pour notre pays et un vrai
potentiel d'emploi pour l'avenir les
industries agroalimentaires et l'agro
industrie doivent faire partie du
redressement productif dont la france a
besoin mais pour parvenir à ce résultat
nous avons besoin de temps comment la
france peut-elle peser au niveau
européen pour qu'il y ait une suspension
de cette décision et la mise en place
d'un calendrier d'extinction des
restitutions si telle est la décision de
la commission européenne
quel faux pourraient être mobilisées
pour permettre la mutation de la filière
avicole dans des conditions sociales
acceptable et économiquement viable
quelles mesures peuvent être envisagées
pour éviter la crise majeure qui
s'annonce et rassurer les agriculteurs
et les salariés concernés
et vous me le permettrais monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues pour
rassurer tout particulièrement les
salariés des entreprises
et qui sait peu implantés sur le
territoire breton
je remercie si monsieur guillaume garot
ministre chargé de l'agroalimentaire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur votre question évoque la
question
la difficile question des restitutions
accordée aux exportations de volailles
par l'union européenne sachez d'abord
que les interventions de la france
depuis de nombreux mois avait permis de
retarder cette décision de la commission
qui est intervenu et néanmoins le 17
janvier dernier et qui a eu pour
traduction concrète de baisser de 50% le
niveau de ces aides
alors vous l'avez noté nous avons
contesté immédiatement à la fois le
fondement économique de l'analyse qui
étaient présentés mais aussi son
caractère beaucoup trop brutale et moi
je veux redire que ces restitutions ne
sont pas un cadeau
ils sont pas un cadeau à notre filière
et ne sont pas un cadeau aux entreprises
françaises elles ont un sens et un sens
économique
elles viennent la soutenir des
entreprises pour compenser en fait les
différences de change et les niveaux de
coûts de production vis-à-vis de pays
extra européens avec lesquels nous
sommes en concurrence extrêmement féroce
alors comment nous avons nous agit
d'abord nous avons immédiatement réuni
dell annonce de la commission
les entreprises concernées donc doux et
tilly sabco nous avons travaillé avec
ses entreprises pour un accompagnement
concret et nous mobiliserons
dans les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines le crédit d'impôt de telle
sorte que ont pu donner un ballon
d'oxygène à ces entreprises au delà de
ça nous sommes intervenus directement
auprès de la commission et auprès du
commissaire ciolos et stéphane le foll
qui le 28 janvier dernier s'est tourné
vers le commissaire pour envisager la
suite
et pour faire en sorte qu' on puisse
aller vers des mesures qui donne le
temps aux entreprises de s'adapter
1 parce que vous l'avez dit ces
restitutions ne sont sans doute pas
éternel encore faut-il donner aux
entreprises la capacité à s'adapter dans
un délai raisonnable mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que nous devons et vous avez
très bien dit maintenant regarder devant
penser à l'avenir moi je veux quand même
le dire que depuis dix ans
nous ne cessons de perdre des parts de
marché sur cette filière avicole
aujourd'hui nous importons 44% du boulet
que nous consommons et pendant dix ans
et bien la présidente majorité n'a rien
fait ou n'a pas fait grand chose mais il
faut le dire s'il faut le dire
aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui nous devons je vous le
disais regarder devant et prendre des
mesures concrètes c'est ce que nous
allons faire dès la fin de mois je veux
dire que la filière avicole
elle a un avenir et je veux dire la
confiance revenir aux serveurs et je
veux le dire à l'ensemble des salariés
nous nous battons pour l'emploi pour
l'emploi agricole mercier pour l'emploi
dans nos industries agroalimentaires
merci la parole et à monsieur jean louis
masson pour la réunion administrative
des sénateurs de figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe
mais ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre des personnes âgées
madame la ministre la famille est la
cellule de base de notre société
à juste titre les parents ont
l'obligation d'assurer l'éducation de
leurs enfants
et réciproquement les enfants au ensuite
l'obligation de s'occuper de leurs
parents âgés
hélas ces deux principes sont trop
souvent oublié
ainsi la presse a évoqué récemment le
cas d'une personne de 90 ans qui avait
été renvoyé de sa maison de retraite
parce que depuis depuis deux ans sa
famille refusait de payer sa pension en
accumulant plus de 40000 euros de dettes
le directeur de la maison de retraite
alors été dénigrés au motif que sa mère
sa méthode aurait été trop expéditive
par contre vous savez très bien madame
le ministre que lorsqu'un résident d'une
maison de retraite ne paye pas à sa
pension se sont indirectement les autres
résidents qui en subissent les
conséquences et qui en font les frais il
n'est donc pas possible de fermer les
yeux
le laxisme en la matière serait synonyme
d' irresponsabilité
madame le ministre au lieu de s'en
prendre au directeur de la maison de
retraite comme vous l'avez fait il
fallait mettre en cause
l'indignité des deux enfants de sept
personnes âgées qui refusait de
s'occuper de leur mère et de subvenir à
ses besoins
c'est d'autant plus scandaleux madame le
ministre qu'ils en avaient largement les
moyens puisque l'un est gynécologue dans
un grand hôpital de la région parisienne
les attaques répétées contre les valeurs
familiales finissent par conduire à de
telles dérives et je tiens ici à le
déplorer solennellement madame le
ministre
qu'envisagez-vous de fer à l'encontre de
ceux qui abandonnent leurs parents âgés
ou qui refusent de les aider à subvenir
à leurs besoins
plus généralement en raison des
restrictions budgétaires les conditions
d'accueil des personnes âgées se
dégradent actuellement est liée à
notamment plus assez de personnel dans
les établissements
or vous avez pris le prétexte du triste
fait divers sus évoqués pour suggérer un
gel de la tarification des maisons de
retraite
je tire la sonnette d'alarmé car si vous
ne compense et pas financièrement et
vous n'avez rien proposé eh bien
l'incidence on sera désastreuse sur la
qualité de l'hébergement et des soins
pour les personnes âgées dans les
maisons de retraite madame le ministre
vous oubliez que si aujourd'hui
la france est ce qu'elle est c'est grâce
aux générations qui nous ont précédés
nous avons donc à leur égard un devoir
de solidarité en faisant tout notre
possible pour que les personnes âgées
soient prises en charge dans de
meilleures conditions
madame michèle delaunay ministre charge
des personnes âgées et de l'autonomie
monsieur le président mesdames et
messiers les sénateurs ce n'est pas en
disant des contre vérités que l'on fait
avancer le débat
je n'ai jamais parlé du gel des tarifs
des maisons de retraite
j'ai parlé de leur mise et je viens de
le faire tout à l'heure encore de la
leur mise en meilleure adéquation avec
le montant des retraites et leurs
revenus des familles vous nous le
pouvons aller plus avant dans le fossé
qui se creuse entre le montant moyen des
retraites est le reste à charge pour les
familles or ce qui concerne la retraitée
de chaville la nonagénaire de chaville
nous avons été tous très ému par cet
événement très fâché je respecte à ce
point les personnes âgées que je ne peux
concevoir que l'on met sans qu'elle en
soit informé une personne âgée de 90 ans
dans une ambulance sans s'assurer que sa
famille peut l'accueillir permettez moi
de poursuivre je ne peux l'accepter
je ne peux l'accepter et je le pense
vous aussi et quand il y à des erreurs
commises par une maison de retraite
nous devons nous en inquiéter j'ai
demandé aussitôt à la rs d'île de france
à l' ars d'île de france une enquête
pour établir les faits et autant sur la
signature du contrat de séjour sur les
conditions que sur les conditions
d'expulsion
la maison de retraite a contrevenu à la
loi ne croyait pas
que je n'ai pas connaissance des
problèmes financiers qui ont eu lieu à
l'intérieur de cette famille et que la
justice viendra très probablement
résoudre c'est d'ailleurs pour cette
raison que j'ai pris
j'ai fait le choix de ne pas évoquer
individuellement et je ne le ferai pas
ici le cas particulier de ses quatre
enfants qui dansent en effet pas
répandue à leurs obligations
c'est en effet un poids tout à fait
important et comme vous l'avez rappelé
le code civil nous impose pour nos
enfants comme pour nos ascendants de
subvenir en ce qui concerne les biens
fondamentaux mais ici ça n'était pas le
cas puisque c'est une personne qui avait
une retraite de d'importance
pratiquement en adéquation avec le
maudit le montant de la maison de
retraite donc vous le voyez j'ai su pour
ce qui était de ma responsabilité mettre
en avant ce qui avait été une violation
des droits de la personne âgée en
établissement droit que nous allons
préciser explicitées et conforter et
d'autre part j'ai laissé à la justice de
mon pays
le droit de résoudre et probablement de
sanctionner les fautes individuelles des
personnes âgées des membres de la
famille merci madame la ministre les
chers collègues nous en avons fini avec
des questions d'actualité je vais
suspendre la surf sera reprise dans 10
minutes pour l'examen de la proposition
de loi adoptée par l'assemblée nationale
relative voilà on en a fini avec cette
séance de questions d'actualité tout de
suite on refait la séance